there was a National Guard recruiting
video
that seemed to be selling more than
recruitment it seemed to be selling
I was an active duty Army Brad and all I
wanted to do growing up was be part of
the military and serve my country and be
part of something bigger I waited until
don't ask don't tell was repealed so I
actually joined when I was 32. my MOS is
12 Alpha I'm an engineer officer and
that means both the construction type of
engineering building things and making
bridges that also means combat
engineering which is building obstacles
destroying obstacles demolitions all of
that fun stuff when I became an officer
infantry and armor weren't open to
females in the combat side of
engineering wasn't open until about 2016
or so I was drawn to it just because I
like the technical aspect and again like
getting my hands dirty and my teams have
always been very welcoming it's about
what you know it's about teamwork it's
about taking care of your soldiers so
really as long as you show that you can
build trust in your team and that you
take care of your people gender doesn't
matter
gender doesn't matter
if our army believes that gender doesn't
matter
I guess we ought to just pack it in
right we better build some really big
walls around our country because we're
never going to win another War again
because it means that our fighting force
on whom we depend to protect us doesn't
know the most basic aspects of human
nature
of course
the vast majority of people in the Army
in the National Garden throughout the
military they know that this is complete
nonsense
but the leadership the people making the
dazzling recruitment videos the people
calling the shots
even if they don't believe this they're
saying this
gender doesn't matter
and it's considered it doesn't matter
back when I was looking to join
women do you believe this women weren't
even allowed in combat can you believe
back when I was going to join the
military we were such a backwards nation
that we didn't even send our daughters
to get blown up by jihadis but now we're
much more Progressive we're a much more
virtuous and Progressive nation and
we're going to send our little girls out
there to get hacked up and tortured and
exploded by evil men all around the
world
aren't we so much better now
women in combat that's considered to be
the height of progressivism in this
commercial women in combat is a national
scandal it is a disgrace it is a deep
deep shame in stain on our country
and I don't even hear the conservative
politicians talking about this
women in combat is a very recent
phenomenon as the lady just said in that
commercial
and yet we just totally gave up that
fight
why because we don't want to be seen as
disrespecting women who serve in the
military I have the utmost respect for
women who serve in the military I'm
deeply grateful for their inclination to
serve and sacrifice
but
the military is not about individual
desires it's not even about individual
ability
it's about cohesion and unity and
National policy and who we want to be as
a nation I have no doubt that's that
there are a significant number of women
who would valiantly go out and risk
their lives and bodily Integrity To Go
Fight For America I don't want them to
do that
I think it's bad for America to send
women into Harm's Way I think part of
the reason that we have an army so that
we don't have to do that right now head
on over to geniusell.com Knowles our
friends of Virginia cell sold out of
their Dark Spot Corrector and our
listeners have been begging begging like
dogs for a restock well I've got great
news it's back in stock genu sells
famous Dark Spot Corrector has not won
but three Cutting Edge ingredients goes
to work fast to Target sunspots dark
spots liver spots even old discoloration
on your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniusell's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials
such as their best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed at how quickly you see
results or 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to genucel.com
right now get your dark spot corrector
in the geniusell most popular package
that is geniusell.com Knowles right now
save seventy seven zero percent off
geniusell's most popular package all
orders include a mystery luxury gift
while supplies last I love the owner
capture Christian from Egypt came over
here for the American dream go to
geniusell.com Knowles
I think it's disordered I think that
women are more nurturing they're the
weaker sex they're the gentler sex and
a major reason to have a military is to
protect them
because boys need their mommies and
husbands need their wives and societies
need a nurturing feminine element and
when we're talking especially when we're
talking about fighting in Lethal Force
we need to not be sentimental and not be
absurdly ideological we need to send out
the toughest strongest brawniest fellas
the reason to keep women out of combat
is as much for the men as for the women
it's as much for the civilians as for
the Fighting Force
and you need to say it even even
moderate Democrats said this 10 years
ago
and now the conservative right wing
won't say it
this is this is a little bit of a
political warning too
things are polarizing pretty quickly
if you haven't learned that in the last
seven years you're probably not going to
learn it the political winners the
politicians who win the political
movements that win are going to be the
ones that are bold they're not going to
be the ones that pussyfoot around every
single little issue and they say well
actually you know look I'm all for
certain radical sexual ideologies but
only starting at age 18 not at age 17.
okay maybe starting at age eight but not
at age seven okay listen I'm for women
getting blown up in combat but I'm not
for them joining the Navy SEALS or
whatever I don't know you're not going
to have a middle ground here on a lot of
these issues the voices that are going
to be rewarded are going to be the Bold
voices who are offering a genuine
alternative this has always been the
best Insight of American conservatism
and it comes from people like Phyllis
Schlafly who this woman who
single-handedly killed the radical
feminist Equal Rights Amendment in the
late 20th century
she called for a choice not an echo
if the libs if the conservatives rather
are just going to be lib light if
they're just going to be squishes if
they're just going to order us slightly
more efficient version of democrat
policies but you know with lower taxes
or something
not only is that not going to help the
country and the society they're not even
going to win elections because people
are just going to vote for the Democrats
I've made this point with the problems
of the DeSantis campaign right now if
the DeSantis campaign is just running is
the better version of Donald Trump it's
going to lose because even if people in
a blind taste test prefer New Coke as
the focus testers at the Coca-Cola
Corporation discovered back when they
reinvented the recipe when people take
that blindfold off and they hear that
they're getting something new they're
not going to like it they're going to
want the OG okay
so you have to offer people a choice not
an echo boy what a great clip that was
now make sure you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time